all right we're getting to the phone
lines got bobby in modesto
bobby how can we help you all right
thank you guys for taking my call i
really appreciate it sure buddy what's
on your mind
so i was calling um about a year and a
half ago me and my wife we
uh we moved in with her with her parents
my in-laws
and um we were 35 000
in debt a year and a half ago we moved
in and in that year and a half we were
able to
pay off all of our debt with the
financial peace university and all that
stuff
way to go bobby we're ready to go man
hey thank you man
and uh we have we're working on our step
three which is uh
i think we got about 10 grand close i
think a little under 10 grand
uh in our baby step 3 and we're looking
good you know build that to about
20 22 000 um
but we're in we're in a one bedroom in
her parents house and it's me my wife
and my
two kids and a newborn and so it's been
it's been a little stressful lately uh
brother bobby that is
that's the understatement of the century
my man
i mean man it's been tough man it really
has
um but the good thing is that you know
we knew we knew it was going to be a
little rough
but knocking out that debt getting
getting our money in order and and uh
you know really seeing progress there
has
has helped ease the process a little bit
we've kind of just made it
you know made it work she's not working
right now i'm working
i had gotten laid off confessing march
and uh but then i got a job by the end
of march i got a job working uh with the
garbage company and i've been working
even more i was making more now than
what i was making before that's right
and giving my tithe giving my offering
savings
and really just believing the lord uh
you know that he's gonna provide a way
and stuff like that now
my question is it is taking a little
stress on our on our marriage
uh me and my wife our kids and
everything and we're we're in a position
where we can move
into a place for rent and have our own
place which i know is needed
um i'm just kind of like debating okay
is this
time to move because of the marriage and
i know that is very very important and i
don't want to
put more stress on it than needs to be
especially with our situation
do i kind of talk to my wife and say you
know whether hold on a little bit longer
or let's get to our six months of
emergency fund and then go out
with everything going on with coving and
stuff uh it's been a weird year even to
step out and get into a
you know uh hey bobby bobby yeah
y'all should move yeah you should move
tomorrow oh yeah okay
move tomorrow uh i can even hear in your
voice you know the answer to that
tomorrow's pretty soon so i'm being
sarcastic um you need to sit down with
your wife sit down with your in-laws
and let them know hey we got 30 days or
60 days go find a good apartment
and um okay y'all have done man you have
you you have epitomized sacrifice you
all made a hard plan
you are an absolute ninja you and your
wife
and i'm just gonna change your
terminology she is working
real hard she's just working inside the
home not outside the home
and y'all done it man you're paid off
you're halfway towards
your six-month emergency fund slow down
a little bit now now you're gonna have
to refocus and re-energize put some
put some love and some energy back into
that marriage bucket three kids will
wear anybody else
anywhere anybody out much less all
crammed in a one-bedroom
um one bedroom room right but good for
you guys
you all kick some butt you're an
inspiration to folks across the country
um but yeah it's time for y'all to move
out yeah i agree i think you know
getting back talking to his wife
setting up the time frame being able to
communicate up
front and clear with the in-laws so they
can start to prepare for this everybody
mentally and emotionally can start to
move down the path
and i i think i agree with you i think
it's in-laws are going to miss the kids
of course they are and so let's just
talk about babysitting yeah and we're
gonna have to deal with feelings with
this
because the in-laws are gonna feel like
look we opened up our home for you right
now you're just gonna take our
everything out you're just gonna take
the grandkids and leave
or they may be laying in bed every night
going come on get out of my house
out of my house of my house gosh
remember we just had one basset hound
how quiet everything was
right remember when the remote didn't
walk away oh man
you left it in one spot yeah yeah you
know what
it could be a little bit above it's
gonna be a little bit about but you know
what as adults
you talk about it right man lay it out i
like that and i
he you could hear it in his voice
couldn't you he knew he knew
he's ready he's like boy this has been
rough it's been a sacrifice
but you know what you did make a
sacrifice you all they opened up their
home
you all i'm sure were respectful in it
and you were able to make progress
so now it's a matter of it's time to
move forward now i am going to encourage
you get over to ramsey plus
so you can start building your budget
now and what that's going to look like
with the new rent and the utilities
and the things you all haven't been
paying so we got to go ahead and start
to build that budget 30 days out and
let's start living
according that's the process my friends